- Good afternoon.
As many of us prepare to
travel home for the holidays,
we have the opportunity
to see some friends
that we haven't spoken
with for quite some time.
- It's a time for
reminiscing and remembering,
sitting down and catching up.
When we leave our home towns,
it's important to figure out
what we should do on Facebook to catch up.
Nothing.
(whooshing and squeaking)
It was fun seeing you guys,
but we don't need to pretend
like we're gonna stay
in touch on Facebook.
- John, I know you're happy to hear
that my parents are doing well.
You told me in person.
There is no reason for you
to tell me again on my Facebook wall.
- Hank, no, I haven't seen Jake.
I don't know why you think
I'm the authority on Jake.
We all graduated and went
to different schools.
- Katie, we dated in high school, okay?
There's no need for you to pretend
that you're happy that
I have a girlfriend.
Also, those double dates
you keep posting about,
they're never gonna happen.
But I am happy you found Mitch, though.
Seems like a chill dude.
- Dave, yes, Anchorman was a funny movie,
and I know it was a special moment for you
when we saw it for your birthday,
but I stopped quoting it, like, years ago.
Keep it off my profile.
- Justin, yes that picture of us was cute,
but I have a bunch of BFFs.
I can't just cling onto that third F
for someone I basically only spent
a couple summers with.
- Wait, you have another BFF named Justin?
- Yeah, I told you that, right?
Justin Hendricks.
We were, like, inseparable
during summer camp.
- Oh.
- That was a long time ago.
- And that's incidentally our hashtag
to raise awareness for who
you went to school with.
- So when your friend from high school
that you used to be really close with
tries to comment on your Facebook again,
just kindly remind them--
- Thank you, and happy holidays.
- And it was good seeing
you, though, Katie.
Tell Mitch I say, "Hey".
(soothing music playing)
(whooshing and squeaking)